well we begin this newsour with missile
attacks in Syria and Iraq which the US
is calling Reckless Washington has
condemned Iran over the strikes the
Revolutionary guards say they launched
ballistic missiles that hit Israeli spy
headquarters in Northern Iraq missiles
and drone attacks also targeted ail near
the airport at least four people were
killed six wounded the prime minister of
the semi-autonomous Kurdish region says
the attack is cowardly Teran also
targeted Isel and Syria and retaliation
for bombings in Iran earlier this month
well let's speak to Mahmud abdulwahid he
joins us now from Baghdad Mahmud I
understand that the local authorities
are saying that these were civilian
areas that were
hit well that's what the uh Regional
government in in Iraq's semi-autonomous
Kurdish region says that it's a an act
of aggression and a violation of Iraq's
sovereignty those missile attacks that
targeted as it as civilian areas leaving
uh civilian casualties uh deaths and
injuries but on the other hand as you
know that Iran's revolutionary guard uh
stated that it is targeted spy
headquarters and Gatherings of what it
calls anti-iran terrorist groups inil
the capital city of Iran
Northern semi-autonomous Kurdish region
now the regional government inil is
calling on the federal government in
Baghdad to take strict measures uh
against those uh violation violations of
its sovereignty in fact it calls on the
International Community also to take
strict measures against those uh uh
violations we understand that Iran's uh
uh Brooky forces in Iraq have been uh
carrying out similar attacks since mid
October targeting us and Coalition
forces uh uh troops and mil military
facilities in Iraq and Syria but this is
a new development a new development that
the Revolutionary guard is taking
matters into uh their own hands and
using ballistic
missiles M ABD there were the latest for
us from the Iraqi Capal thank you Mahmud
well let's now bring in dorsa Jabari she
joins me here in the studio dorsa you've
spent an enormous amount of time for us
in Teran talk us through what Iran's
thinking right now what's the calculus
for them at the moment well they needed
to respond uh they've been uh talking a
big game since October 7th and uh given
the recent developments on the ground
inside Iran the uh attacks that were
carried out in kmon and the number of uh
revolutionary guard Commanders that were
assassinated in Syria and uh what Israel
has said that about Iran being behind uh
Hamas fully supporting them and then the
houthis so there's a number of different
factors that came into play uh to carry
out these uh strikes now the most
important point is that these are
multiple ballistic missiles that were
launched from Iran itself Iran didn't
use any of its proxies to carry out
these attacks attacks talking about uh
and they Ed their longrange missil and
they hit Targets in Syria in idlib
Province so it's quite a far distance
for these missiles to go there's a few
things IR on is trying to achieve with
this first is to Target specific uh
people that they wanted to get they
claim that it was mad um ground training
grounds or facilities in ail and then in
Syria U spots belonging to isil the
other thing is to deliver a message to
the United States and Israel
uh mainly that to reiterate Iran uh
Iran's military might it it's well known
in the Middle East Iran has the biggest
um missile Arsenal in the region and
using these ballistic missile long range
it's certainly going to deliver that
message and a reminder to the US and
Israel that Iran has the capabilities uh
and the third is also to um quiet some
of the internal criticism Iran has been
facing over the past few months for not
doing enough for not responding strongly
enough to uh what's been happening in
the region in terms of how the United
States and Israel have been moving
forward and carrying out uh various
assassinations and attacks in Regional
countries um and blaming Iran for uh
what is at the root cause of the issues
really interesting Dynamics DSA Jabari
thank you for joining us this news hour
well let's now bring in Muhammad mirandi
he's a political analyst and and also a
professor at the University of tan he
joins me now from the Iranian Capital
Professor this appears to have been a
very targeted operation seemingly a
calibrated response How concerned are
you about Regional escalation those
fears have been very very real for for
many watches since October the
7th everyone is concerned about
escalation except for apparently the
Israeli regime and its American Allies
almost from day one uh the Iranians
along with uh many others across the
region have been calling for a ceasefire
and the Americans have been refusing to
support a ceasefire and so have most EU
countries alongside the Americans and as
the fighting went on and as the genocide
in Gaza grew worse uh the fighting began
to spread Hezbollah in the uh North they
have been fighting literally from day
one uh they've given 150 or so Martyrs
because they have been trying to draw
away the Israeli military from Gaza and
more recently ansar has been putting
pressure on is ships going to Israeli
ports to build on more pressure to end
this this Holocaust and of course the
resistance in Iraq has also been active
to put pressure on the Americans to end
this but uh so far we haven't seen
deescalation we're only seeing
escalation I think uh the strikes that
the Iranians have carried out are both
to Target mad offices and uh terrorist
organizations but also to send a message
to the Israelis and the Americans that
this escalation will hurt them more than
anyone else well let me ask you more
about this because some of these strikes
they took place in an area around the US
Consulate as I understand but it was not
hit the building itself so what is
teran's message to Washington right now
is this just about a a show of military
might or does it go beyond
that many of the offices of terrorist
organizations and the Mad are very close
to the US Consulate because that they
feel protected but the Iranians were
sending both striking these targets
because unfortunately Northern Iraq is
heavily infiltrated they were both
striking these targets but also they
were telling the Americans they were
sending a message that our missiles are
very precise and we're not afraid to
Target these offices these bases near
your buildings again I think it's both
to strike at these Terror groups and
those linked to the mad but also telling
the Americans that Iran has tremendous
power and that you want stability in
this region if you want the oil markets
to be stable if you want the economy
across the globe to grow this ceasefire
has to be put in place well as we were
just hearing from dorsa this was Iran's
revolutionary guard themselves not an
Iranian proxy as we've seen before
should we read anything into
that well I don't believe Iran has any
proxies these are all Iranian allies
whether in Yemen Lebanon Iraq in Iraq
these the Iraqi Armed Forces alongside
the Iranians fought on the ground to
defeat Isis the same ISIS group that was
H that was created thanks to Western and
NATO intelligence agencies but uh so
they're not proxies they have agency all
these groups these resistance this
resistance front from Lebanon to Yemen
to Gaza itself and Iraq Iraq Iran
everyone is putting is piling on
pressure gradually to force the
Americans to end this this Holocaust we
wake up every morning to see dead bodies
on our on our cell phones on on the
television screen this has to end and if
it does not end when War continues
things will happen and it will
automatically push the the region
towards greater
escalation Muhammad Mandi the professor
at the University of tan always great to
have you thanks for sharing your
thoughts
sir well Iraq is now saying it will take
legal measures against the actions which
it describes as an aggression in a
statement the foreign Ministry has said
it considered the attacks a violation of
Iraq's sovereignty and the security of
its people